don't make me older than I am 1999 I
came to Yale well thank you so much
thank to Kurt for inviting me I love the
science Saturdays and I really am
looking forward to just sharing some of
the work that my colleagues and graduate
students and postdocs and I have been
doing here at Yale and right from the
you know to just start off what I'm
interested in these days is looking at I
mean what I've always been interested in
is looking at the fundamental structure
of the human mind how are we inherently
built to understand the world to make
sense of what's going on around us and
to figure out you know how to place
ourselves in that world and this is a
very old question that's been around as
long as the philosophers and the
particular question that I'm focusing on
these days was put especially well by
John Barth in the 1960s I'm looking at
the fundamentals of human nature is man
a savage at heart
skinned over with fragile manners just
like gleaned on the surface after
culture and education and civilization
or is savagery but a faint
Tate in the natural man's gentility
which erupts now and again like pimples
on an Angels arse so this is this
question has been around as long as the
philosophers have been around what are
humans fundamentally are we
fundamentally good are we fundamentally
evil and I've got a couple of quotes
from you because people have been giving
both answers as long as people have been
around to pose this question so Lao Tzu
who is was an ancient Chinese
philosopher and the founder of Taoism
believed that humans were fundamentally
good every human beings essential nature
is perfect and faultless but after years
of immersion in the world we easily
forget our roots and take on a
counterfeit nature other people have not
been quite so optimistic Albert Einstein
said famously it's easier to denature
plutonium than to denature the evil
spirit of man so this is what we're
fundamentally asking and I just want to
say I very much welcome questions to
come up as we go along if you have
questions about the scientific studies
that I'm showing you or about the
results or just if something's not clear
it's no sense listening to a talk where
you're not actually understanding it so
I encourage you to just put up your hand
if you have questions and we'll go along
and if it turns out we get into some
interesting discussion and don't finish
the official talk that is totally fine
with me
so just stick up your hand and if if I
don't see you you know let me know that
you've got a question how have I been
choosing to address this these types of
questions about human nature I have been
there's a lot of ways that one can do it
I've chosen in my professional life to
study babies when I at least started I
was a graduate student at MIT and I
started in the cognitive science program
and I didn't start studying babies at
first I started studying preschoolers
and then down to toddlers and I just
became convinced there's a lot of
interesting ideas
and concepts that these young little
children are bringing with them already
and that led me to study babies and the
reason I chose babies was because um and
there's a baby in case you haven't seen
a baby recently want to know what they
look like you know and the question is
how can babies help us answer these
types of questions the reason I study
babies is the story the general idea of
how we get to be the adult humans that
we are is we start off these are our
minds as babies somewhat not fully
formed and then we have all the tools of
Education and culture and learning and
what our parents tell us and what our
friends model for us and so on and that
at the end of it
there we are well formed adults so I'm
really interested in what does this
stuff look like at the very beginning
and I like to view the baby mind as a
really good example of the human mind
before it gets all of those corrupting
influences of language and education you
know this is the human mind as it is
born before it has had a whole lot of
experience and learning and you know it
could look a lot like this very unformed
but a lot of the studies that have been
going on looking at babies mental lives
in the last few decades have found it
may still be made of plasticine and have
a lot of changes and updates that can be
made to it but it's got a lot of things
already packed into it so here's a
magazine cover that was came out on life
in about 1994 somewhere like that says
they can add before they can count that
was actually my first baby study ever
that I that I ran in 1992 when back in
the days before time began they can
understand 100 words before they can
speak and at 3 months their powers of
memory are far greater than you ever
we've learned a lot of things so we've
learned that babies actually have an
ability to do some forms of arithmetic
believe it or not we've learned they're
born knowing what phases look like you
can take a baby that is one minute old
and they will rather look at a human
face than almost anything else in the
world they're already built somehow in
the uterus they were definitely weren't
seeing faces in there they have in their
brains an idea of what the human face
looks like and people are so important
to them that that's what they want to
interact with and pay attention to more
than anything else in the world they're
born recognizing their own language and
this relates closely to the follow they
can learn even while sleeping so while
they're sitting there having naps in
mom's tummy they are getting some noises
that come through the abdomen wall and
through the amniotic sac and the
amniotic fluid and they can actually
hear mom's voice and they can hear what
language she's speaking and become
familiar with that language this general
sounds of it and can tell it apart from
another language and they already know
mom's voice when they're born so they
have a lot of powers of learning and a
lot of rich built-in types of knowledge
or understanding or thought processes
and so it's these that I've been
studying and the particular questions
that I've been focusing on in the last
about decade are the early what we might
call the moral life of babies questions
of do babies recognize good from bad and
also you know what about their own
natures are they born to be good or bad
so this brings us to the question of how
do you actually study babies and get
into their heads because if any of you
have seen a baby recently how many of
you actually live with a baby so you
guys have definitely seen a baby
recently how many of you saw a baby
recently yeah so you know babies can
babies run mazes like a rat
no can babies tell you about what
they're thinking can you ask them
no because some babies when they get old
enough like maybe after a year or most
babies like by the time they're 18
months and I would say then they're an
18 month old would not want to be called
a baby so I would stop calling them a
baby by the time they could talk to me
but little babies do little babies talk
yep they say things like ver ver ver ver
ver but they don't understand what
you're asking
them a lot of the time they may
understand some simple simple stuff but
but they can't tell you until they're
about at least 18 months old on average
so how do you take somebody that can't
talk and can't you know the way we study
animals who can't talk in psychology is
we put them in mazes or teach them to
learn things like press a lever over
here to get a food reward if you can
tell that there's you know greater than
five five light flashes if we wanted to
ask if if rats can count but babies
can't even press you know they're not
going to do that so how do we get into
the minds of babies there's a few things
that babies are really good at doing
they're good at crying they're good at
pooping we don't measure those we just
made a decision early on they're good at
playing and they're good at some really
sorry at sleeping they're good at
sleeping they're good at a lot of things
one thing they can do right when they're
born is they can open up their eyes and
look at things and they love like I said
they love to pay more attention to some
things than other things and it turns
out they love to pay attention to things
that they really like like faces and
once they have a couple days of
experience with their mom's face or
their dad's face they'll love to look at
those faces more than other things and
they also look longer just like you
might that's something that's unexpected
surprising to them develop you know we
may not see their eyebrows lift up
they're not going oh my god mom what was
that but they don't do all that but they
do pay more attention to things that are
unexpected or surprising to them so we
can measure how long they look at
different types of things that was how I
actually ran my baby addition and
subtraction studies I showed them one
little doll going behind a screen
another little doll going behind a
screen
how many dolls should be behind the
screen to down comes the screen and
maybe there's two but maybe there's only
one or maybe there's three and we just
measured how long our baby's looking at
these and golly don't you know what I
found
babies are looking longer when it's just
one doll or when it's three dolls they
gave little short looking time when it
was two dolls so we use that to say
looks like babies are expecting two
things to be there and they're surprised
when it's the wrong number so that's one
technique we can use we measure babies
looking two different things a different
measure is babies are good at liking
some things more than others and they're
good by the time they're about five
months old they're pretty good at
reaching for toys or reaching for things
they're interested in which often aren't
always toys but maybe your keys or your
cell phone in direct proportion usually
to how valuable and breakable they are
or how deadly dangerous they are right
the really sharp knife or the electrical
cord all those things babies love and
are attracted to so we can show babies
situations and the met this stuff that
I'm going to tell you about today mostly
involves showing babies little puppet
shows where the puppets behave in
different types of ways and then at the
end of it we ask babies which puppet do
you want to play with and just use that
we're just asking them who do they like
better the one who acted like this or
the one who acted like that so this will
become really clear as I go along I have
two parts to my talk because we've got
the nature of good and evil so
we've got the moral baby and this is the
first part my colleagues and I we were
really interested in the question do
babies have any understanding of what it
is to be nice and treat others well or
what it is to be mean and not treat
others well do babies judge others by
their behavior so this is what we showed
babies I'm not gonna you just see it you
can be my subjects even though you're
not babies but alright that's incident
one
okay who wants to tell me what did you
see happen there yeah
exactly that triangle was trying to get
up the hill the circle pushed him to be
nice the square pushed him to be mean
did you do you feel like you have a
different attitude do you feel
differently about the circle and about
the square if you had to pick one to
play with
would you care which one no you'd like
them both the same you're a lot bigger
than them so they couldn't push you
around right yeah all right anybody else
have anything you want to add mm-hmm the
triangle the one that was climbing
uh-huh
you I like you all right so we were
really interested in little babies do
they have different opinions about the
helpful character and the unhelpful
character so we would after seeing our
situation we just give babies a choice
between the two characters now what do
you think I'm gonna ask you you can be
scientists right now put on your
thinking hats do you think babies would
have a different opinion about these two
characters uh-huh what about you again
ah whoa good scientific thinking what
about you
all right so you've got both the
hypotheses out on the table maybe they
know the difference and if they can tell
the difference they'll like the nice one
if they can't tell the difference they
won't have a basis to pick mm-hmm so
we've got a lot of things here and I
want to pick up on something that a
couple of you said cuz it's really
important maybe babies do like read
better than blue or maybe most babies
are right-handed are gonna pick the
thing on the right so what do you think
we would do to make sure our experiment
was built to take care of those types of
issues
that would have been one way to deal
with the hand in this question what we
do are do you have an answer to this
question or do you add a new question
hmm okay what is it you think they would
like to circle yeah
so what we did the way we dealt with
these concerns is for half of the babies
it's the red square that's the mean guy
and the circle that's the nice guy and
for the other half of babies it's the
circle that's the blue circle that's the
mean character and the red square that's
the nice character and for half of the
babies the nice characters on the left
and the mean characters on the right and
for the other half of babies it's the
other way around
so if most babies like red more than
blue they might most of them pick the
red character we'll see that but we'll
know it's only half the time that the
red character is the good guy and the
other half the red character is the bad
guy so this is called counter balancing
we just make sure that other things
babies might care about aren't gonna be
aren't gonna be right well then we're
gonna be able to tell apart whether
they're always picking the good
character from whether they're always
picking the red character yeah did
someone up there have another question
so if you turn the video upside down the
effects would be the opposite I like
that I like that so do you want to see
what they do alright actually before we
even see what they do I'm gonna describe
a couple other things to you some babies
are too young to reach out for the
objects we've tested three month old
babies so we don't ask them to reach
because they're too little we ask them
who do you like to look at more and
babies tend to look at things that they
that they like so here's a baby reaching
this baby saw exactly what you just saw
and this is a six month old she's
getting the choice and that's what she
does here's a couple other situations
we've shown babies here's a character
sees a nice toy inside of this box so
let's try to open the box but he's not
very good at opening the box Izzie looks
like he needs a little help all right
what a nice grey kitty and here he is
again he's gonna try opening that box
again and what is the orange kitty gonna
do all right
and then here's one last type of
situation we've shown babies okay I've
got a ball here I'm playing with my ball
oh I'm going to invite you to play with
me are you going to play back with me
we're taking turns here are you gonna
join in okay so the orange bunny joined
in the game and accepted the invitation
to play what about this green t-shirt if
bunny what is this one going to do is he
gonna play with the other one
now is that friendly went away and took
his fall so for all of those we asked
who does baby prefer and here I'm gonna
give you a chance to be the scientist
and you can code this baby this is a
three month so she's looking and you can
just see an ear here from one of our
puppets and there's an ear that you'll
be able to see in just a second so she
has two puppets in front of her one of
them was nice in one of our situations
one of them was mean and now you can be
the coders and see if you can tell which
one is she looking at more OOP okay
play which one is she looking at I knew
this was gonna happen which one is she
looking at more are you ready here she
goes
and for bonus points you can even say
does she look like she might have a
little bit of different emotional
expression on her face does she smile
more at one of them than the other
that's very hard to tell in little
babies though
all right so that's the kind that's what
our data look like how many of you
thought she looks longer at this one huh
how many of you thought she looked
longer at that one yeah it's pretty you
know we uh we obviously we take a
stopwatch and measure really carefully
but it's pretty you know we can we can
get you know babies like to look at
these characters and so we get a lot of
looking from them so here are the actual
data these are graphs and the graph
tells us what percent of all the babies
looked longer at the or or reached for
the nice character that's the babies in
blue or the bad character and the only
thing you need to recognize in this
graph is which is bigger the blue bars
or the red bars the blue bars are way
bigger because almost all of our babies
about 85% of our babies reached for the
nice character or if they were three
months old looked longer at the nice
character and this these bars just break
it down by different ages and what
different scenarios they saw but it's
the same pattern across all the babies
so how do we prevent experimenter bias
that is a really important question we
know that humans love to get what they
want right and we have great powers of
wishful thinking and we can even
misperceive things and get it wrong we
can think we're seeing what we want to
see just because we want it so much so
what we do is the experimenter who
offers the toys to the baby doesn't know
who's the nice character and who's the
mean character they have no idea so they
can't be thinking oh I hope she picks
the red one I hope she picks the red one
because if they were thinking that they
might themselves smile more at the red
one or even totally unconsciously hilts
the board a little to make the red one
just a little bit closer to the baby and
babies reaching is actually surprisingly
hard for very young babies to do it's a
lot of work and one toy being an inch
closer than another doesn't sound like a
lot but it could be a lot for a baby and
they might reach for the close friend
well the experimenters can't do anything
like that if they don't know which
character is the nice one in which is
the mean one all right
turns out these judgments are really
important to babies they don't just
choose the nice character more than the
bad character but they have a long
memory for it a student in my lab Arbor
to see me decided to see if you show
babies one of these it was the Box Joe a
nice character helps open the box a mean
one closes it will babies remember that
a whole week later so we brought the
babies into the lab a week later and
only at that point did we give them the
choice but babies are still choosing the
good guy a week to ten days later saying
that they really remembered who's the
nice character and who was the mean
character all right well how much does
it matter two babies are they
willing to put their money where their
mouth is now we know that babies by the
time they are ten months old and eating
solid food they love cookies and graham
crackers these are little graham
crackers and babies are no dummies like
I told you earlier if you give them a
choice between one graham cracker on
this plate and two graham crackers on
this plate which one do you think
they're gonna crawl to the two cuz
they're no dummies just like you we're
all no dummies were like that's an easy
choice
what if it's puppets who are offering
these two plates to the baby and what if
the nice guy has a plate with just one
cracker and offers just one cracker and
it's the bad mean puppet who offers two
okay who would you take a graham cracker
from you take the one graham cracker
what about you uh-huh or the mean one
you couldn't can't trust the mean one
maybe he's dunce
maybe those crackers are suspect what
about you
can you say it that again just a little
bit louder because I couldn't hear from
way back
mm-hmm
so the baby might not expect yep
mm-hmm yeah well shall we find out what
the babies do do you want to know we
gave babies exactly this and most of the
babies decided like a lot of you said
they're gonna take the one cracker from
the nice guy they're willing to give up
a cracker just to not have to interact
with that mean character okay what about
this situation Oh No
you're gonna go for the eight yeah
what do you how many of you are gonna
now choose to accept the offering from
the mean guy to eight crackers how many
of you are there any bit of you that
would still just take the one from the
nice guy you guys are kind of mixed and
you know what our babies were kind of
mixed two more of them chose the eight
crackers from the mean guy but still a
third of our babies we're still being
holdouts and saying not even for seven
more crackers yeah
because say that because of why yeah
then you're a big guy like if he gives
you any trouble you know game over for
him he's picked the wrong you know you
weigh about a hundred times more yeah
well two thirds of them chose the eighth
one so you're right about most of them
but a third of them were still holdouts
so yeah in the first situation they
always chose the nice characters about
85% of our babies so it's always a few
that shows the mean character but the
the big majority always chose the nice
characters in all our situations so I
love these findings for two reasons one
they tell us it really matters to babies
they're paying attention to how folks
are treating others in the world and
that's really important to them the
other reason I love these findings is
hooray
even in infancy there's a cost to being
a jerk in the world
that jerk had to offer up a whole heap
more in order to kind of get back into
the good graces and have babies be
willing to interact with him or her we
didn't you know we didn't ask you know
we don't know what sex our puppets are
so him or her and here every now and
then a baby this is a young toddler
about eighteen months of age will
actually spontaneously give an
interaction watch what this kid does so
that was the mean puppet he didn't like
him and sometimes not too often but
sometimes babies will pick up one of
them and hug them and it's always been
the nice character so far when they do
that so are these moral judgments well
there's certainly squarely in the domain
of moral judgments they're judging how
you know they're judging an individual
on the basis of how that individual
treats someone else
that's you know that's the domain of
moral assessment and the other
interesting thing about it is okay this
do you all recognize who this is this is
Lady Justice with her blindfold on why
does she have a blindfold yeah a
blindfold and a balance scales because
she is unbiased she doesn't know who's
who she's not paying attention to the
particular identities she's making her
judgments the same for everybody and our
babies are unbiased in this sense they
don't have you know it's not that
they're friends with one of the puppets
beforehand it's not that they themselves
have been treated sorry I just banged my
microphones it's not that they
themselves have just been treated nicely
by one puppet and mean by another
they're watching interactions between
strangers they've never met before and
even at three months watching
interactions between total strangers it
comes through loud and clear to them
this is this one's treating another
nicely this one's treating another badly
so I'd love to just end my talk here
because it's such a nice positive note
babies little angels human nature is
fundamentally good babies will save the
world if we just give them you know if
we just elect them to Capitol Hill you
know they can set solve all the world's
problems and make their be world peace
and put everything to rights again but
remember there were two parts to my talk
and so here we come to part two now this
is the depressing part of the talk but I
just want to say from everything I've
said so far if you meet a baby and that
baby's looking at you like this I submit
to you that it's not just gasps that
that baby is making a judgment about you
and you so far have not fully impressed
that baby so you may want to up your
game you've got a very short window of
time to you know cause that baby to
think a little better of you
they're making judgments all the time
about people alright so for this part of
my talk I want to throw you out a
question there's all kinds of reasons
why we might like some people more than
others what I've talked about so far is
babies liking some people more than
other people
puppets people puppets but you know
characters more than others on the basis
of how they treat others but there's
other reasons we might like someone more
than someone else what are some of the
reasons we like some people more than
others aside from their behavior
yeah if you've known them a little
longer
absolutely familiarity is one important
reason important influence on our liking
and what about for new people that we
just meet yeah we know the world loves
attractive people more than unattractive
or plain or ugly people there's all
kinds of data showing that attractive
people get better jobs and get paid more
money and you know we also are fortunate
that we recognize that's not a thing we
like and we try to correct for it but we
we do you know attractive people tend to
be liked better
are there other yeah maybe they're happy
we definitely like happy people better
people that are positive and make us
feel good and just look like they're
upbeat about the world their attitudes
definitely there's all kinds of reasons
one of those many influences is we tend
to like others who are similar to us in
various ways and the reason I chose this
picture is just to point out and
emphasize it's not just humans who do
this it turns out preferring other
individuals who are similar to yourself
we can find this tendency all across the
animal kingdom even fish of course fish
that are the same species often school
together but II
even within a school of the same species
there's some species of fish that make
individual friends in their school and
and have their own fish buddies that
they like to hang out with and the fish
buddies who are buddies with each other
tend to be more similar than if you just
took any two fish from the school at
random so we can find this across the
animal kingdom a tendency to like other
individuals who share certain
similarities with us ourselves and it
turns out for adults in the in
psychology labs anyways almost any
similarity is sufficient to create some
amount of preference you can take adults
and bring them into the lab and give
them a quarter and tell them to throw it
and it comes up heads or it comes up
tails and then you tell them well some
other folks came in and rolled this
quarter and for some of them it came up
heads and some of them it came up tails
and now we don't do this explicitly if
we asked adults explicitly who do you
like better I would hope that all of you
would say that's a stupid question I'm
not gonna like someone better because
they also threw a quarter and it came up
tails just like when I threw it but if
you asked them not to make a conscious
comparison but just to make a judgement
let's just only ask you about the one
that got tails just like you how smart
do you think that person is that you
never met you never even saw a picture
all you know about them is they got two
tails just like you well I don't know
maybe they're four points on a
seven-point scale maybe that's how smart
they are or I'm gonna give you a dollar
how much of that dollar are you gonna
share with this other individual that
you're never gonna meet who also got a
tail just like you oh I guess I'll give
them 50 cents
another bunch of subjects you ask about
the person who grave got heads instead
of tails and oh I guess there's three on
a seven-point scale of smart and maybe
I'll give them 30 cents so people aren't
aware that they feel differently about
individuals but they do and it doesn't
matter what the similarity is it can be
such a stupid dimension as did you throw
a coin toss the same way we like others
who are similar to us and and prefer
them in a variety of ways that we can
measure
so we were really interested in the
origins of this is this something that
we learn by being in a world where it's
very important to affiliate with others
who belong to our own social group or is
this something that is it part of human
nature from the get-go so do babies like
other individuals who are similar to
them now as one of you mentioned we
already know babies like others who
they're familiar with so we thought and
thought what is a dimension of
similarity that won't just be
familiarity and we decided similarity of
opinion so our question is going to be
do babies like other people puppets who
have the same opinion as the baby so
here's a baby we're gonna ask this
baby's opinion about two toys there's a
green car there's a yellow helicopter
and she has just expressed that she
likes the yellow helicopter better so we
can ask now this bit you know this baby
likes the yellow helicopter does she
like she's now gonna get introduced to
two puppets one of them likes the yellow
helicopter but not the green car one of
them likes the green car but not the
yellow helicopter here's what that looks
like you can see it down in the bottom
here
okay and then the other puppet just does
the opposite and likes the other toy so
now we ask who does the baby like now
she gets to choose okay and and what we
find well first of all let me tell you
we've done it with toys which toy do you
like better we've done it with mittens
look we've got orange mittens and yellow
means which mittens would you like to
wear baby and they pick and we'll put
the mittens on their hands and then the
two puppets each say oh I like this one
but not that one so we put mittens on
the two puppets hands and babies get to
choose between the two puppets we've
done it with foods we've done it with
two foods we're bait we know babies like
one of them more than the other
which one do you think they like more
than the other the graham crackers yep
and we've done it with food too where we
know babies feel the same about them
both babies love graham crackers and
they also love cheerios and here's what
we find any guesses it would be seems to
go down the wrong way if babies would
actually prefer the one that was
different
it's dissimilar right they might either
have no preference or they might prefer
the one that's similar does anybody have
any different intuitions yeah
oh that's an interesting so if if the
puppets then chose something else the
baby would pick the thing that the
similar puppet chose we haven't done
that that is a great idea for a study
you want to join my lab you think about
it let me know in five years maybe ten
so here is what the babies actually do
blue is the number of babies who chose
the puppet that had the same view as
them and picked the same object and red
is the ones who chose the babies who
chose the one that was different and you
can see babies are picking the similar
guy and this was with seven month olds
and eleven month old so they're picking
the other puppet that has the same views
as them and about 83% altogether so okay
well that's fair enough
right most of us when we think about why
we decide to be what makes us want to be
friends with somebody more than another
almost all of us we have something it's
because we have something in common with
them we it's natural to choose friends
because we have common shared interests
why might we be built this way what's
what's the advantage of having this be a
fundamental part of human nature so
fundamental that we don't even have to
learn it but are born with it and can
show it by the time or just a few months
old I think there's a few different
reasons why it might be useful first of
all if you like raspberries and someone
else likes raspberries you're gonna be
going to the same places you might know
a patch that she doesn't know about and
she might know a patch that you don't
know about so you might benefit by
sharing information and strategies with
each other and by joining forces maybe
you can collect more raspberries than
otherwise sometimes you may not actually
care about the person's preference
itself but the fact that they have the
same view as you on something is an
indication that they
I belong to a similar group as you now
in these days we tend to like a whole
lot of international cuisines so it's
not as strong of a queue as it used to
be but even so if you meet someone and
they like a plate of fried spiders which
people do eat in places in the world I
grew up in a place where we never ate
fried spiders and I I've missed my
window of opportunity to develop a taste
for them because they just you know I
would just I'd run away I'd run out of
the restaurant and down the street I'm
not gonna eat them if I meet someone who
loves a plate of fried spiders probably
they grew up in a different culture than
I did and come from somewhere far away
and aren't you know didn't originate
from my group of people my peeps we
don't necessarily like this about humans
that we tend to prefer individuals that
belong to our own groups but this is
very powerful force around the world and
even if it's something that you don't
care about by itself it's fine with me
if someone has this taste or that taste
the fact that it's the same as yours or
different from yours
may tell you something important about
what community that person belongs to
and then the other reason is this is how
special interest groups we have formed
we've been a very social species for as
long as humans have existed we've not
only had to have conflict with different
groups of people that are different
cultures and different ethnicities and
different races living in different
countries the ones that we commit war
and fight with and genocide and all of
that but we've also had to argue and get
our own way within the community within
which we live there's always been
politics there's always been us having
to decide to go get the big game in our
hunting or we're gonna go upriver we're
gonna go downriver and some people think
we'll won and some think the other and
they have to get together and try to
convince everybody they're right so most
of the adults in the audience if you're
at work and have like faculty meetings
or group meetings where the group has to
it's something you know pick your group
where you have to get together with
other adults and decide things and
there's different opinions and you can
find people sorting and try and
collecting together in big group you
know gathering everybody that's of the
same view as them to try to you know
convince the others and get their way so
there's a lot of reasons why it might be
useful to be attentive to whether others
are similar to ourselves but like I said
it's fair enough to choose your friends
that way we don't you know some people
actually choose their friends cuz
they're different and new but when we
see most of our babies choosing the
similar there's nothing bad about that
all by itself but if we ask babies how
do you want these other individuals to
be treated that's where we start to say
okay we as a reflective species who does
have moral ideas we can say individuals
shouldn't be treated differently just
because you know the person who likes
graham crackers just like me shouldn't
be treated differently than the one who
likes Cheerios instead right so how did
we ask this question well babies come
into our lab they choose between two
things then they get introduced to the
two puppets one chooses the same as the
baby the other chooses the opposite and
then for half the babies it's the one
who chose the same as the baby say the
one who chose the graham crackers is
trying to open our box and somebody's
nice and helps them open the box and
somebody's mean and slams the box lid
shut so we asked babies who do you like
between the helper and hinder the one
that was nice to the guy similar to you
or the one that was mean and of course
for the other half of babies it's the
character who chose differently from the
baby the one who chose green beans
that's trying to open the box and
someone's helpful and someone slams the
box lid shut and we asked those babies
who do you like more the one that was
nice to the one who it was different
from you or the one that was mean or
maybe you don't have a preference at all
so what do you think what do you think
babies are gonna do what about when it's
the puppet that's like me that shows the
same is the baby who do you think
they're gonna like the one that helped
it the one that pushed the box lid shut
or they don't care yeah the one that
helped it let's see
you are right babies just as strong as
always preferred the nice guy what do
you think about when it's the puppet who
chose different from the baby that
they'll choose the helper because it's
nice to be a nice person what do you
think
so maybe they'll choose the hinder and
what about you help her
shall we see I was really disappointed I
wanted to go take all my babies and have
a little talk with them I was very sad
to find that just because they liked the
graham cracker and the other puppet like
the green beans they actually liked the
puppet who is mean to that one um so
there's a little hole in the lady
justices blindfold she's you know babies
are can make judgments as disinterested
bystanders but they're not totally
disinterested they're letting other
facts flow through we also wanted to
know do babies have different
expectations about these characters so
this is the one study we ran that used
looking time remember babies tend to
look longer at things that are
surprising to them so when we showed
them the similar character who chose the
same as the baby being nice to somebody
and being mean they looked a lot longer
when that character was mean suggesting
they were surprised by that and expected
the one which the same the one with the
same view as them to be nice but they
didn't have any idea uh they didn't look
longer when it was the character who
chose differently from them it's like
you're different you're foreign and
unknowable and I can have no
expectations about you so I want to sort
of wrap up now and first of all what
does all of this stuff say about babies
well in a nutshell it says that babies
are smarter than you think there's a lot
of detailed evaluation of the world and
attention to details and a lot of
judgments going on in their heads
even in the very first months of life
but the bigger question is what does all
this say about us as humans
I started out studying babies not
because I was interested in babies
though actually now I'm long decades
after I started I'm really interested in
babies now and think they're actually
very very interesting special subtype of
humans on their own but I started
because I was really interested in
what's human nature well one thing that
this says is that we can now answer John
Bars question and say we're neither just
good nor just bad as our fundamental
human nature we've got both both sides
of the coin a human nature we're both
good and bad even from birth we can see
the ability to distinguish nice from
mean and to prefer individuals who treat
others well but we can also see forms of
bias that intrude in ways that we don't
want our society to be governed by so
we've got built-in ideas of nice and
mean we've got built-in attitudes
towards individuals who are like me and
individuals who are different from me
and when you're talking about a three
month old or a seven month old these
notions have not been instilled in them
through learning and education and
culture they they came with the babies
they can't they come with us probably in
our DNA hardwiring all right well like I
said I was disappointed in those babies
that actually were like eating - the one
that chose different from them I like
someone who's mean to you we would like
ours our whole world to have people get
along recognise our differences and not
get into all kinds of skirmishes and
Wars and traumatic
difficult conflicts over these
differences so is there anything that
studying babies could possibly have to
say could it be helpful at all in this
type of endeavor yeah
that is such a great question in case
you didn't hear would be do babies like
other babies more than a fully grown
humans how many of you have a little
baby brother or sister at home and how
many of you it are you your baby brother
or sisters favorite person in the family
well you know it turns out it's a
complicated question right cuz maybe mom
or dad is the favorite person when the
baby's hungry but maybe you're the
favorite person when the baby wants to
play we do know that a lot of babies
seem to be very attracted to other kids
maybe not other babies but other kids
that are a few years older to them and I
think that this may be actually one of
the ways that development happens is
that kids of all ages are especially
intrigued and attracted to kids who are
just a little bit older than them a
little bit further on the developmental
scale you know they've gotta know how to
do a few more things and they're cool
and you know when you think of who do
you want to be like who do you want to
dress like who do you want to act like
often kids are looking up just a little
to the age just above them and that may
be how we aspire to and end up becoming
adults and being driven to to always be
looking forward so alright so can
findings from babies be helpful if we
have a core liking for similar and a
dislike of different we can ask
questions like what is the effect of
highlighting all the diversity of
humankind we know a lot of schools are
really paying attention to this question
and want to have encourage tolerance for
and appreciation of diversity but there
might be a real difference between
simply saying look we've got all these
different kinds of people in the world
that do things differently versus saying
look everybody's really similar in these
important fundamental ways we all love
our family members we all
a good meal around the family table and
so on and it might be that these two
things these two types of messages
behave very very differently and are
received very differently by a system
that is built to value similarity and to
devalue difference so I'm gonna end
there and I will take questions but any
of you have to leave feel free to leave
but that is the end of my official talk
I'm just sensitive to the fact that
we're just about it noon now so I know
we're at the end of our official time
but I'm happy to take questions from
anybody that has more questions they
want to ask you had a question you had
your hand up I saw you don't want to ask
it now you're all done okay not as
rapidly no and they can change their
well there's they definitely like what's
similar to what they know and what's
familiar so if you if you look like my
parent you're on the ends yep yep okay
thank you all very much